nabil boudi avocat pénaliste au barreau
de paris sia bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
le 11 juillet ce ne sera pas la fin de
l'état d'urgence selon vous est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer sur le plan
législatif et juridique également oui ce
sera pas la fin de l'état d'urgence
on nous parle de sortie d'état d'urgence
il ne parle pas de faim d'état d'urgence
c'est principalement la ce terrain qui
pose problème puisque la majorité et le
gouvernement sont en train de nous
expliquer gentiment que les dés lors où
la pandémie n'est plus d'actualité sans
dire qu'en français les mesures
d'exception qui ont été prises depuis le
départ doivent prendre fin
c'est de la part du gouvernement une
manière de nous expliquer que finalement
l'état d'urgence doit se terminer
en l'espèce ce n'est absolument pas le
cas pourquoi on est son principal le la
fin de l'état d'urgence annoncée labarda
majorité du gouvernement
elle n'est pas suffisante puisque il ya
un point qui pose problème au jury s'est
d'ailleurs c'est l'objet de la tribune
que nous avons co signé aujourd'hui avec
d'autres confrères et des universitaires
c'est là le droit de manifester et c'est
ce qui pose problème
on a un précédent en france c'est l'état
d'urgence sanitaire post attentats en
2015 souvent vous que la majorité
précédente à les utiliser
l'état d'urgence post attentats pour
réprimer les manifestants la coop 21 et
interdire certaines manifestations et
j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement avec cette prétendue sortie
l'état d'urgence est en train de héros
de reproduire exactement la même chose
c'est à dire qu'on va utiliser la
maladie cette fois ci
et on n'est plus sûr du terrorisme quand
justifier les restrictions sur le sur le
droit de manifester et c'est
principalement la problématique est
posée par ce projet de loi la question
que pose aussi ce projet de loi ce sont
les restrictions dans le cadre d'une
crise sanitaire vous parler des
manifestations mais ces restrictions
elles vont certes elles sont peut-être
nécessaire aussi vous avez nous étions
opposés des départs à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui avait été adoptée dès le
déclenchement de l'épidémie ont
considéré que tant sur la forme sur le
fond que cette voie poser problème pour
une raison très simple c'est que le
droit actuel en france et notamment le
code de santé publique
permettez au gouvernement de procéder
par décret donc manière très rapide sans
soumettre les textes aux assemblées de
prendre certaines mesures l'état
d'urgence n'était pas nécessaire pendant
l'épidémie
alors que dire maintenant à la fin de
l'épidémie que cet état d'urgence fait
cette sortie d'état d'urgence n'est
qu'une manière pour le gouvernement
selon nous avocats et juristes de
continuer à procéder à certaines
interdictions
j'ai l'exemple du frappant c'est une
manifestation vous savez il a pas mal de
contestation et on l'a vu pas plus tard
qu'hier il ya un certain nombre au corps
de métiers et les avocats aussi qu'ils
sont en colère face au projet de réforme
des retraites
on a vu les médecins hier il ya eu des
questions des violences policières
donc si on si le gouvernement décide de
sortir l'état d'urgence sanitaire
il doit le faire de manière intégrale au
nom de quoi
l'exposition qui concerne le droit de
manifester sont maintenus dès lors on
considère que l'épidémie il ya plus de
risques sur la santé de nos concitoyens
le droit de manifester doit être
la vie intégralement sur la question des
risques pour les citoyens justement ça
reste encore en suspens parce qu'on
n'est pas certain encore que cette
épidémie elle est réellement dernière
nous et c'est ce que je viens de vous
expliquer le premier ministre peut
procéder par décret il peut rétablir de
manière très rapide et très efficace
certaines dispositions qui étaient déjà
dans les dates dans le dans la loi de
l'état d'urgence interdit sial afin de
prévenir de n'importe quels risques sur
la santé des français
il ne faut pas utiliser le prétexte de
la santé des français pour faire passer
des textes qui sont particulièrement
liberticide ce chantage lié à la santé
des français selon moi ne permet
uniquement le de la restriction de la
liberté de manifester donc vous êtes
persuadé vous que c est la liberté de
manifester le droit de manifester
justement qu'elle remet en cause par un
faux projet de loi ce que je dis c'est
très simple on se sert de cette épidémie
d'ailleurs viennent nous expliquer que
nous ne sommes pas sans me faire
insulter tout le territoire français
donc pourquoi certains rassemblements
peuvent avoir lieu dans des commerces
dans les transports en commun reste
juste derrière vous savez maintenant
dans les avions tout le monde est assis
côte à côte
donc pourquoi une manifestation par
exemple créer plus de risques sur la
santé des français que un rassemblement
dans des commerces ou ailleurs et dans
le même temps la manifestation d'hier
elle est pas autorisé 1
alors justement il ya eu 1 le conseil
d'état a statué en début de semaine où
la fin de semaine dernière par don c'est
un camouflet au gouvernement en
expliquant que c'est exactement ce que
j'ai à vous dire dans la mesure où les
gestes barrière existe ou la ville
son cours normal surtout des records
français la liberté de manifester ne
doit pas être une exception donc par
conséquent le conseil d'état qui lui est
une autorité administrative est une
institution administrative a décidé que
l'on considère que le gouvernement
prenez les mesures qu'ils étaient
libérés et d'ailleurs c'est en cours de
réflexion de la valeur est
particulièrement attentif vous savez le
régime du droit de manifester en france
est un régime déclaratif
c'est à dire il vous suffit de faire une
déclaration à la préfecture pour pouvoir
manifester le gouvernement serait en
train de réfléchir actuellement pour
procéder mac cette fois ci un régime
d'autorisation c'est à dire que la
préfecture bah vous autorisés à
manifester
donc c'est tout ce qui est lancée
actuellement autour de cette question là
merci beaucoup à vous un avis de woody
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat pénaliste au barreau de paris